oh okay alright I am knocking stuff over
and I don't even know what it is hey
everybody
am i up folks see me hear me
everything good greetings from Scotland
oh hey there dalam greetings from Oh New
York New York whereabouts Gabe I used to
I did used to live in New York Wow
I lived in Queens technically but it
might as well live in Brooklyn that's
that's Ridgewood for you I don't
technically I lived in Queens but like I
took a Brooklyn train into Manhattan ah
now which end of Brooklyn the hipster
end of Brooklyn or the far end of
Brooklyn thata quite like the clunk of a
hollow can how's everybody doing tonight
ah what country outside the US would you
ever want to live in live I don't know
I'm I'm a typical American and that I
don't know any language other than
English so you know English speak he
would be good the water is present yes
of course
how was Gallifrey one free oh hey
Rebecca how was California one for you
it was great meeting you there in person
it's funny I would kept running into
each other over the con yeah I had a
great time I it's kind of funny but like
it's also kind of expected because for
as much as there was going on it's a
relatively small space for how big a car
actually is so it wasn't too surprising
it was thanks to bump into you so yeah
why don't we actually
please start there why don't we start
talking Gallifrey 1 now I am going to be
putting together an actual like full
video recap of my experiences from
Gallifrey one would like footage of
cosplays both mine and other people's
and and stuff like that but I haven't
had the time to put it together yet so I
haven't really gotten to talk too much
about about Gallifrey 1 it was really
really cool I had a fantastic time there
and I got to meet more than a number of
very cool people I met Rebecca who you
seen the chat I met Carolyn our mod also
a very wonderful person
um and I also got I got recognized a
fair bit which I I don't know how much I
expected to happen
I definitely figured that I would be
recognized more than at like a standard
con like so like when I went to terrific
on last year I got recognized I think
three times the entire weekend this time
I was a lot I recognized a lot although
it varied from day to day depending on
what cosplay was in so like I wasn't
recognized as much when I had the hair
pulled back doing either 12 or 10 and 10
was fine because I actually drew on
sideburns which no didn't seem to throw
anybody off but like what I pointed them
out there they were drawn up he was like
oh so it's suppose things that that
passes surprising muster did you watch
the masquerade I did the the cosplay
masquerade thing it was very it was her
go there's some very neat cosplays up
there you had product in your hair Vera
um I'm in a freezing-cold attic in
Yorkshire UK at 1:00 a.m. just don't
blame me for that okay you did I'm glad
you're joining us from that location but
uh do you go to any events or cons in
New York um I haven't and it's not on
the top of my list because um after
living in New York for four years I'm
just kind of over it like and and I eat
like I can find some enjoyment in the
city but getting there between the drive
and especially getting about the city
either having to pay for parking or god
driving around it at all even just to
get to a parking spot like a garage or
whatever oh it would take a bit to get
me back to New York I'm not gonna say
never but like it's not not in my plans
oh I've got sideburns that's nice doctor
I can see the pen sideburns I've got
sideburns just don't rub them they
smudge did you think Jody Whitaker is a
bad actor do you think the writing is
bad whoa William that's uh that's a
harsh tone to come in with um no I don't
think I don't think any of the lead
actors on the show are bad actors I
think the writing has been inconsistent
it is better I feel this series than it
was in series 11 it's not perfect but
especially going back and read in my
rewatch most series aren't they can't
all be series for a tradition do it
homework on the live Oh Freddy
at least you've avoided any alien
visions in NYC I'm sorry to start hard I
did it's fine William it's just like the
wordy I was like boy that's a that's the
I mean I'm not mad at you for asking the
questions just like that was the
negative angle to come up the that
inquiry from I'm not going to go through
all the swag that I I ended up procuring
at the at Gallifrey one but I am gonna
go over a couple of things because
they're readily a hand an alien invasion
happens do you fight or flee depends on
the nature of the invasion and what I
have to hand so one thing I definitely
want to show off this I picked up this
ring and so you know it's nice it's
pretty and mm-hmm that my friends
mmm-hmm that's a poison ring I also got
one for Liz because I think it would
have been an imbalance in our
relationship for me to be able to poison
her but she can't poison me so I have
one that I need to give to her as well
is it weird that whenever I hear you do
an English accent I hear the empty child
are you my mummy did you meet
Christopher Eccleston I did ever so
briefly but I did I got a picture with
him and I got him to sign it so yes I
did get to meet him and he was lovely
I'd like to cosplay the second doctor
but I feel I'm too hot and tall to pull
that off sadly I people get weird when
with some of the things that they think
qualifies are disqualifying stem from
certain cosplay and a height is one I've
never ever bought I don't buy into
weight either honestly like if you want
to go with a cosplay that more naturally
fits your size that's fine but like I
don't think anyone should be restricting
who they play based on their way
restricting who they play based on their
height I just I don't agree with that
mentality I think that's a silly reason
to not do it
excuse me love that ring it is so cute I
know I know right it's lovely
oh look what's that oh it's gone here
have a drink
I can't cosplay Jabba the Hutt I'm too
skinny for that no one is big enough to
actually just straight up cosplay job at
the height you're always gonna be padded
you're allowed I was a young fan who did
them the moment / bad wolf oh that was a
that was a good one in The Masquerade a
lot of fun
imitating I'm glad that you saw yes
Gracie that was great I'll I mean
because like I I don't dislike rose but
Billie Piper playing the bad wolf entity
is my favorite thing she's done on the
show so I loved that that was great
when your partner your partner make sure
they buy you a poison ring so they
didn't just as easily murder you
relationshipgoals do the scene from
boomtown with the ring oh god I almost
forgot that was in there
Eccleston does Doctor Who cons didn't
know that well Mr Al this was the first
time that he has done a Doctor Who
specific Khan so it was actually a
really big deal that he was there and I
I think this is me projecting a little
bit but I suspect that he might have
been a little nervous coming in um but
by the time he left he was all by the
time I Khan was over he was all smiles
he was just seemed to like he was really
warmly embraced everyone was just so
thrilled to have him there and I saw his
interview on Sunday morning which meant
I got to be in this massive room as we
all sang happy birthday to him and he
did say with a big smile on his face
best best birthday ever so I think we
gave him a good enough experience that
he might do more Doctor Who related
events we'll see no pressure on the guy
at his own pace but yeah it was very
cool progress maybe Big Finish next
fingers crossed on that I would love him
to pick up some Big Finish work but
again at at his at his own pace um I'm
really happy for the guy I got his book
still need to read it I also want to
track down with more stuff with him in
yeah he's he talked quite a bit about a
stage work as well
quick question but which master was you
cause but Missy don't don't even act
surprised by that oh I had one other bit
of merge that I wanted to show off
because it is readily reachable from
where I am so I walked past this
repeatedly and I like knowing that I was
going to end up buying it but I held off
for a while so I picked up this now
here's the first question let's see how
big a nerd group I'm actually dealing
with how many people know what this is
based on sight alone so let's see what
we get there Missy was the best master
I still think Delgado was the best but I
I would love to roll into cosplay Missy
there were a bunch of it there was a
Missy panel with three Missy cosplayers
it was awesome Chinese puzzle box puzzle
box dice roller clothes Karen what it is
is it is a dice tower so this like this
is so wonderful and got got lady with a
sword on it and came with all right
didn't it didn't come with but the this
particular one I got a set of dice with
it which are these I got him in
Slytherin green and these these are
metal
dice according to the person who I
bought it from they are very carefully
machine mathematically perfectly
weighted but just I have a dice tower
now ooh
15 that's not bad depends on what my
what my modifiers are I might be a good
shape but yeah so I think that's all I'm
gonna show up because most of the rest
of the stuff that I bought um like I
picked up some Big Finish sets I picked
up the war doctor series one and Mistie
series one I've started listening to the
war doctor series one and like I picked
up gifts for other people and and things
like that ah perfectly balanced says all
things should be
ooh that's ominous I'm a Gryffindor hope
we're not enemies I we don't have to be
it's like see the thing is the thing to
remember is Slytherin Gryffindor
ravenclaw hufflepuff they are
personality types
they don't determine what your values
are they're only a type of personality
in way that you sort of go about
approaching things now grifters and
slytherins may be more prone to butting
heads slightly but like whether or not
you and I are enemies has a lot more to
do with your values than whether or not
you know you're a stubborn blowhard with
your head up your own but like most
Gryffindor's oh god how many subscribers
if I gotta lose for that one I'm sorry I
could not resist um do you think Ryan is
leaving I don't know like I guess the
vibe off the last episode I feel like
we're in a situation where anybody could
go which is kind of exciting to feel cuz
like I never felt the only person I ever
thought we were gonna lose before was
Graham in series 11 but that wasn't
because of any sense
the episodes towards the end that was
just because I assumed Bradley Walsh
wasn't gonna do more than one series so
I really I'm enjoying the nervousness
I'm getting of this feeling like maybe
we will lose some buddies so I don't
know um got my first physical Big Finish
myself not at a con but still the sixth
doctor the last adventure oh yeah I
heard that was pretty good starting to
think thirteen is a bit of a ravenclaw
versions of the master are Slytherin
yeah I'm not sure I can um I can dispute
that I I think I'm pretty sure I sorted
thirteen into Hufflepuff when I did that
video I think last year I'm really a
ting that after this series um I'm not
sure where I would put her yet though
which companion European is having the
best season right now this season it's
yes it took a couple of episodes before
they remembered to do stuff with her but
once they actually started paying
attention to her I've really liked the
development Anya's this series which is
good because she needed it she had she
had nothing to do series Leben at all as
a ravenclaw i stand with your Gryffindor
shade hahaha
I heard someone will die next episode do
you think it's true well I mean if
you're saying a main cast I don't know I
think it's possible am I predicting it
not really but then again I'm not much
of a predictor anyways that's not my jam
that said we'll probably devolve into
that at some point along this evening
I know but me and slytherins don't get
along very well but I think I'm more
like a Hubble hufflepuff like my cousin
I mean like couples are great like can
we just like I'll agree with that you
know pride from my own house and
whatever but helpful circles are pretty
awesome like just I am yeah
I've noticed this series that yaz has
some similarities with Clara with her
recklessness do you think her story will
end the same way I'm hoping not only
because they did already do that story
with Clara and did it very well
through
the Raven you know before he'll been um
but I so I like that they're revoking
that I'm hoping it's not an indicator of
her meeting a similar end because I feel
like that would be a little lazy to
repeat the beat but I like bringing back
the vibe
mr. charters has convinced Graham is
going thanks to one of his lines anyone
who makes wildd for dictions based off a
single line I'm always gonna be like
yeah sure right Michelle Gomez playing
karela to Phil would be the greatest
sure why not yeah seems to be in love
with the doctor maybe her run away was
about her sexuality um actually I hadn't
thought too hard on it I it would be
interest i I don't need to know but it
would be interesting to find out why she
ran away from home
and if that was possibly a reason again
I don't need to know why she ran away
from home getting the context that she
did was enough for me would you rather
watch fifth doctor stories only for a
year or hellbent only for you I would
watch fifth doctor stories for a year
over hellbent yeah I'm both excited for
this finale and yet quite sir and I'm
going to hate it also Hubble's can be
the most dangerous don't estimate
underestimate how atrocities can be
committed out of loyalty oh I'm not I
did not say hopefuls are harmless so you
know I I am I am careful with my wording
on that like I I've made the argument
that Fano Zsuzsa is an evil huh 'full I
mean you know I I'm go I'm not everyone
agrees with me on that but I am aware of
where things can go south behind on the
chat I'm a Ravenclaw whoo nobody's gonna
die in the finale
they're all in the episode afterwards
they're all in the episode after the
finale did did you did you think that
sentence through before you said it
somebody in the comments the other day
tried to tell me that they thought
something was gonna happen based off the
IMDB credits for who was gonna be in the
episode and I had to explain to them
that I am DB can be changed by anybody
with an account and there are no
requirements to set up an account once
you create one I am DB you can submit
you know additional actors whatever for
anything and it doesn't get fixed until
somebody catches it and clears it up so
never like official for me to you never
use the IMDB as a news source like
looking at a movie that's coming out in
a like in a year or so and like looking
at the guys go oh this person's in it
you know probably not seeing as 12 is
your favorite doctor but he stars on
what I presume is your worst new who
episode does that qualify as a paradox
well no because wasn't his fault he
didn't write it I almost forgot the
order of my lines before I went on stage
Oh
oh boy that there there is a there is
that nerves
well you're not sure if you've got your
lines down as someone who's been doing
you know stuff on stage since middle
school yeah that that's that's a real
thing people call me famous because I
dyed my hair a certain color but it
doesn't look like that it looks like
Barney oh dear Freddy you might want to
adjust that shade uh what would you like
to see in the next companion personality
which time arrow they're from I just
want somebody from some somewhere other
than modern-day like from another planet
from the future honestly I kind of
prefer from the past I would
love another companion like Jamie you
know I I would love that I'm I the show
has been going along enough we don't
need the modern era companion to be the
hook in oh we can't relate otherwise
you're wrong
shake it up I'm so over modern era
companions like above the what's your
favorite episode of new whoo midnight
now it's probably heaven sent
um but but anyway like uh I was I was on
a ramble and now I lost the thread ah
doesn't matter it'll come back to me
would you ever react to review the Sarah
Jane Adventures PS I adore Jamie oh
that's what I was talking about so I had
the template that I want to broken the
template that was modern-day young woman
you know companions and they shook up
you know the young whoa we've got three
companions only one of them's a woman
but we're like two of them are guys but
we're still stuck it with modern-day and
companions and I'm so bored with it um I
Sarah Jane Adventures is just something
I never really clicked with so that
basically goes in the pile of stuff I
was like I don't have a reason to not do
it it's just I have a reason to do so
many other things before that so if
somebody really wants to get me on top
of that had commissioned me and I'll get
to it I just realize oh dang it lost it
backing up just realize I fussed about
my height for a cosplay yet I'm planning
to attempt public cross-play for the
first time in London MCM this year well
there you go
look speaking of someone who has been
presenting feminine to varying degrees
in public for ooh guess about
I guess about 16 years now yeah
being tall [ __ ] me immediately I'm 6
feet before I put heels on so but you
know whatever
governess Clara governess Clara was the
best Clara as none of the companion
sorry friends they're not convenience
anymore they're not even friends their
fam but does not have signed on series
13 do you think all we go I don't follow
the signings because that's stuff that
can and will change on short notice you
know so I'm again like that's a level of
backstage minutiae that I just I don't I
don't like getting into the weeds on
like just for myself cuz it always
changes like you oh this person's and
talks and I may never sign on like you
devoted all this energy the thinking
about this person in this role and it
was never seriously gonna happen like I
just don't like going down that path um
I think there should be more Ninth
Doctor cosplays the Ninth Doctor here's
the thing the Ninth Doctor is
simultaneously easy and difficult to
cosplay it's a very straightforward
outfit but it completely passes for just
a normal outfit so it can be unless
you're a something like Gallifrey one
which is a Doctor Who convention people
are gonna go ah then it's one of those
things like it's that person cosplaying
that's not a knock on the costume that's
just saying for as a cosplay prospect
it's um oh hang on backing up um have
you been keeping up with Picard and pick
Bakar Picard
no I'm behind I need to catch up cuz I
want to do a recap review soon of the
episodes that have happened since the
premiere you mentioned you hate the
theory that the master of the doctor
kidnapped by Time Lords as children is
about what happened with the untempered
schism or am I missing something
nuts
the the thing that I was that I was put
my eyes on is a bit more intricate than
that and I don't want to talk about the
reasons why look here's the thing and
I'm not meaning to be teasing about this
it just really it ate at my brain so
much I hate him I hate the idea of doing
that to anybody else um but when the
finale premieres after it airs when I do
my review I will either lay out the
potential leak that I saw and say I knew
this was gonna happen because I already
found out about it or if it doesn't I
will say what it was that I was led to
think might happen and explain briefly
why I would have hated that but I don't
want to go into details on it it was
more stupidly intricate than that and
not to mention the untempered schism
that's not a kidnapping thing that's
just a thing all Time Lords do they all
do that that wasn't unique to the doctor
and the master at least it wasn't
presented like it was
have you heard the theory about gala
Fran's originating from humans thanks to
the large portal at the end of the ninth
episode I had it but I'm not shocked
somebody floated that one like the idea
of look the the whole range of things of
Gallifrey is really earth skaros or the
earth the Time Lords were originally
humans humans are now sure it's an
offshoot of Time Lords they come from
the same root species etc etc I don't
like any of those I've heard all of them
even before this series I've heard
things like that and I don't like any of
those ideas I think they're stupid I
think they're a lazy twist and I think
that that sort of thing that that is the
kind of twist that makes the universe
feel smaller because you used to have
two things two separate things but now
you've made them one thing you're
consolidating the universe now that
makes it less interesting to me so yes
I've heard and seen and read those kinds
of theories they this is not this series
is not the first time they've cropped up
I hate them I hope they never come true
you're up you are right about IMDB the
Batman with Pattinson last year listed
David Tennant as the Riddler
yeah they did the same thing for The
Dark Knight Rises they listened David
Tennant as the Riddler like I am DB is
the Wild West I know that I maintain my
own IMDB page so who would you like to
return for the 60th if you were in
control if I was in control we would
bring back eight
basically I want to bring back folks who
who weren't in the 50s so let's bring
back eight let's bring back nine if he's
up for it let's bring back seven six
five and let's have Tom Baker cameos the
great curator again that's probably
overindulgent that's just me tossing a
bunch of names out there but um I like I
have no story idea for how to justify
that and let's be honest the five
doctors as much as everyone loves it
it's pretty contrived that's gonna cost
me some more subscribers saying that you
like very like small stories in big
worlds I do that's something I like very
much
so the minute you start to make your
world smaller and condense it and
consolidate it you annoy me
you know Gallifrey has been chosen
referred to as sounds like a place in
Ireland coincidence okay yeah all right
we're gonna start talking about latest
episode of Doctor Who in just a moment
let me catch up the five ish doctors but
in universe retribution haha do you
think dr. Ruth is the timeless child no
but I think they're connected Donna - I
will always want that I want to come
back I just I don't I feel like she
signed off so well and unless they
completely undo the if she remembers the
doctor she burns up thing that I don't
think there's anything that they could
show us that'll have much meaning are
you gonna check the discord I am in
about 13 minutes or so usually do it at
quarter to the hour okay when do you
think it's okay to have a different
actor play a previous doctor uh never
I'm sorry I don't I just I don't I don't
think you should do it
I don't like that they did it with the
first doctor for the five doctors I get
why they did it but I don't think they
should um and I don't think they ever
should I think they should ever do that
ever ever
ever because the minute you open that
door you open up the possibility of oh
well let's have a series a new series of
the third doctor but then the instant
the show has the licence to tell in the
in the show new stories of doctors whose
time has passed then the show doesn't
have to keep moving forward it doesn't
have to keep expanding it doesn't have
to keep going new places it can just it
can turn into a completely masturbatory
exercise as far as creativity goes
because it can just it can just have a
nice little circle jerk
over all the past things that there used
to be and look even going forward doctor
who tends to be rather nostalgic
bringing back old you know monsters and
whatnot but I think about the fact that
since the 90s
Star Trek did not move forward in time
once until Picard started earlier this
year that was my big frustration that
was a big part of why I moved on from
Star Trek was because it kept just it
was navel-gazing it's like Oh Kirk or
Spock remember Oh early enterprise Oh
early days of the Federation Ozai move
forward stop masturbating your old
frigging history and move forward and I
do not want that for Doctor Who ever and
I view the idea of having new actors
play the old doctors has a very
dangerous first step in that direction
that worries me a lot because I saw what
that did to Star Trek as for Big Finish
I'm doing it in Big Finish I'll shrug
and say I won't listen to it if somebody
else want that fine
but no I I hate that idea Mike and I
would love to see Sean Pertwee played
the doctor but his own version I don't
want him to play the third doctor we
have the third doctor don't don't do
that what an 8th doctor TV series work
as a spin-off to Maine who I don't want
them to do a series because then they're
basically made creating their own their
own competition
and then they can then you split the
fandom um if they wanted to do a
Christmas special with the eighth doctor
if they wanted to basically adapt chimes
of midnight uh and and have Paul McGann
come back and do that as a Christmas
special one year I'd be on board for
that sure what was your favorite panel
or interview at Gallifrey selfishly my
favorite panel was the while I was on
cuz I had a lot of fighting a lot of fun
doing it but of a spoiler but discovery
is technically not a prequel anymore
okay I'm a watched any of it but it was
still presented as one for what a Serie
A season two seasons just saying an
episode in Hollywood where it's implied
the doctor ghostwrote Bill and Ted oh if
they were gonna do that it would make me
really wish George Carlin was still
alive to have him sneak in there I've
written fanfiction which state which
takes place after DX ds9 called
deep-space gamma uh in fiction your
panel was indeed a lot of fun Thank You
Caroline um I never really got it to
writing fanfiction that said I did help
a friend try and shoot their fan
episodes of their own scripted Star Trek
thing I think they called it Star Trek
Odyssey but we never finished filming
any of it but it's possible they're
going to repackage one of the reveals
about the Time Lords from
zagreas won't spoil what they were
they've already done their own spin on
the silver turkey yeah which it was
weird to me that some people got annoyed
at the haunting of Villa did it they
were upset they were like this negates
the silver - like no it's a rehab
patients been doing the revive she's
been doing that since series one Dalek
is Jubilee it doesn't erase Jubilee and
Jubilee is better and like and that was
another thing people like yeah but
silver Turk is better yet Jubilee is
better than Dalek da mic system is still
right up side of the show like I don't
know man the things that people [ __ ]
about and hold hold the current era to
the fire for things that like overtly
we're done at earlier points it's it's
weird and annoying the lack of
self-awareness I think is what annoys me
the most I really like your ascension of
the Cybermen review although not sure
about 20 minute long theory about why
the absorbable fits behind it all uh
stick with me I'm gonna be right go back
and re-watch that video and see if I
actually did that or not give me more
clicks please more views a friend of
mine did a lot of fan fics as a teenager
was very erotic oh yeah that's a whole
other area not to mention the universe
has been rebooted since well yes there's
that too have to call deep space scan my
fan fiction because couldn't get any
interest in it it is on Amazon oh cool
um I was like I said yeah erotic fan
fiction that's uh that's an interesting
thing Liz when she was I think I think
it's okay for me to tell you this when
Liz was in college she she hung around
fan fiction communities a bit mostly
Harry Potter there's some interesting
fanfiction pairings that she has told me
about she used to read
but okay hey how are you I'm good Connor
how are you I'm I'm very good
so alright uh did you see the idiot
slander'd sketch show at Gallifrey if
you did what was your favorite sketch i
i watched part of it it's not it's not
really my style of comedy so i did i
didn't stick around for it um to the
giant vampires the sex cloud or and this
is my theory verify go Oh Ben sneaky saw
the movie marriage story today it was
brilliant I have no interest in seeing
that whatsoever zero
do you read manga or watch anime oh not
regularly anyways so so look um oh god I
keep trying to steer this back and um
also wrote Batman stories and a fantasy
novel called bear acts gorgeous or is
called sound of mislaid Souls hmm sorry
mr. L I am not quite following that
sentence um could you see any American
actor taking over the role of doctor no
ah no doctor has to come from the
British Isles anyway so let's talk about
the LAT the that most recent episode of
Doctor Who so I think the big overriding
question right now is imagine Disney
owning Doctor Who
shut your mouth all right so the big
overriding question is
what in the heck was the deal with the
stuff in Ireland and Brendan and who
wouldn't that hell was that what was
that what is going on now here's the
thing
Brendan equals Benny confirmed yes
confirmed um I I don't have an answer I
don't know who he is
um but you know what we can run down
some possibilities so my initial thought
when it started was that he my
assumption by going in was that he was
the lone Cyberman that we were seeing
before he was converted but then when he
got named Brendan because the Cyberman
is Ishod um that threw a wrench into
that and then what happens at the end
doesn't fit that theory at all so that's
gone so that was my first notion um the
natural inclination is that brendan is
in some way tied to the Time Lords and
probably to whatever in the heck the
timeless child is he may himself be the
timeless child don't know but what was
going on at the end seemed very tied to
something not quite regeneration but
something like like something at
something in the same neighborhood as
because the idea that they were going to
reset him and given that we saw him
start as a baby he went through an
entire life from infancy to old age and
then they just wiped his memory and
reset him now again that's not quite the
same as regeneration but it doesn't seem
it's all that different and so the
question becomes if this is somehow tied
to the Time Lords how is this he is
being experimented on by the Time Lords
in which case he might not even be that
special he might just be in an ordinary
frigging human being and the time was
just have that much ability to screw
with people that's possible um is this a
way sort of flashback and he is some
sort of a ted-like was this all like way
in the distant past and some sort of
artificial construct where the Time
Lords are basically or whatever you know
or the gal frames before they even
establish themselves as Time Lords we're
figuring out how to create regeneration
by messing with this guy and rewinding
them and setting him back and da GM or
whatever else again not it's not quite
regeneration but maybe maybe it's an
early step towards that goal maybe
here's what I don't want these are
possibilities but I do not want them I
don't want Brandon to actually be
anybody we know I don't want I don't
want him to be the doctor I don't want
him to be the master I don't want him to
I don't want him to be the Joe Martin
doctor I don't know I don't know I don't
want it so it does I feel like it's
pretty solid that whatever is going on
with him is tied to the Time Lords his
time is tied to Gallifrey itself it's
just a question of exactly what the deal
is
perhaps the timeless child as timeless
as the Time Lords have created him as an
experiment in immortality without
regeneration possible
like those sorts of things are all but
the Rani just to piss you off
it's never the Rani it's never the Rani
and it's never Susan these these are the
only certainties of Doctor Who but it is
Benny
somebody just shoot him then it's never
Omega huh I wish I didn't have to
concede that point huh I kind of do
though I don't like saying that one out
loud though it's never the value it
should never be the value ardh let's
also be clear on that one I don't get
the attachment to the valley hard don't
nothing he's back it's not like what the
Ronny where I just look at the Ronny and
go no the writing didn't work the Ronny
was bad
um the Valeyard wasn't bad I just don't
think it's an idea worth exploring any
further than it already was
you know I seem to be alone in that is
it tomato soup no but I think it might
be potato leek soup
maybe it's Captain Jack's son he
discovered his immortality as an STD if
Jack's immortality is a sexually
transmitted disease then the entire
universe would be immortal by now I
don't think that works it's Darth
Plagueis ha ha ha no no it's just
Palpatine back again how why who knows
who cares
force lightning I do have a class
project on the film 12 Angry Men I'm
glad to return to one of my favorite
movies of all time so Connor I think I
mentioned it I don't know if you've seen
any of the things where I mention it I
was in that play I I was I did 12 Angry
Men
I was juror number six um I think was
sick sick sir set six yeah
sure six God while ago five years ago
huh do you think Brendan is Ruth is the
timeless child I hope not I hope he's
not Ruth you might be the thymus child
whatever you think Captain Jack is hot I
do
everyone does I want them I was like
asking do you breathe yeah it's a weird
question I was five I think it was fun
like that that play I really enjoy that
play I enjoyed that a lot that was oh
man no it's not six it's seven seven was
me okay second biggest jackass in the
room that was who I was
uh big step away from Doctor Who for a
second did you hear about Bob Iger
stepping down at Disney oh that's not
new he's been planning to do that that
was like a year ago I got announced so
yeah no I knew everyone was you 12 Angry
Men see what you did there
I heard rumors that the doctor will be
hey FK for a couple of episodes next
season and the master will be taking
care of Companions thoughts if this is a
possibility I don't think the Sasha
Dhawan masters the one to do that with
if they were gonna do that Missy would
have been the one to do that with so
it's not an uninteresting idea but I
think they got the wrong master cuz I
have a hard time believing that Sasha
diwan's master would just kill them
whereas Missy even before she kind of
had her turn towards the light at the
very end there she was very much she
enjoyed toy
with people for as long as possible so I
could have bought it there hi there I
think this whole series is one master
mind trick still waiting for baby Oda
the real timeless child alright can you
see a masters spin-off they have them on
Big Finish
they're great anyways I got a pop over
the discord for a minute be right back
so and here's your reminder supported me
on patreon at the $2 level gets you
access to the discord it's a patreon
perk and there's a channel on there
where if you ask a question I guarantee
I will answer it in the live stream I
try and keep up with the questions
otherwise but I don't guarantee anybody
except those who do the super chat and
those who are in the discord shameless
plug hmm let's see on a scale of 1 to 10
how crazy bonkers do you expect series
12 finale to be um I'd say probably a 7
I'm not sure Chibnall
is bold enough to go as bonkers as the
set up could go but I think he'll do
pretty solid um what else I got uh whoo
what do we think brendan is basically
just had that whole conversations we
kind of covered that an excuse to bring
Clara back no no I have a couple of
thoughts which I have mentioned in the
who channel but I'd like to take the
opportunity to say how annoyed I am that
you two at youtubers who put rumors and
speculation in their titles makes it
difficult to avoid them I try very hard
not to be one of the people who does
that but yeah yeah I hear you on that
the one bit of the hunting of villa just
villa d thank you for sparing me having
to try and say it that bother me
I'm watching was the doctor's I will not
lose anyone else speech immediately
followed by the first ballet and the
brutal for Doctor Who next snap of the
nurse neither of which even registered
as mattering by the doctor
um like I did have my issues with the
doctor failing to knowledge acknowledge
them but it wasn't because of that
speech because I took that speech as
much less a statement of purpose for the
rest of the episode and much more of a
reflection of the fact that losing bill
still stings but I it does tie in to
where I had issues with that episode so
I'm kind of there with you anything else
weird to think for over 56 years Doctor
Who never had any scenes set in Ireland
until now how much you want to bet it
turns out to be some sort of artificial
reconstruction of Ireland and not the
real thing and then fans can debate
forever doesn't count
accidentally drunk licorice tea vomit
emoji
oh dear why did you even have the Lakers
tee I like licorice like black licorice
legitimately I like it I bet we've got
some somewhere how he loves the stuff I
tend to be lukewarm towards myself
although I do a nice licorice flavored
alcohol like Oh zoo or Jager
Yeager's nice Jager is fun if you ever
chase Jager with a shot of maple syrup
real maple syrup not that crap you get
in squeeze bottles those go together
nice um God that was probably the most
Vermont statement I've ever made I put
in the wrong d bag it was meant to be
meant the discourage of all this is an
entire conversation about licorice and
licorice tea Oh standard builders tea
kind of girl would with milk and I
discovered a recently honey see I just
go straight tea for me like I'd like
Lady Grey is my default but you know
Earl Grey jasmine
mint on occasion and I don't add
anything to mine
morty conversation he's opening the
questions they were just legitimately
having a tea conversation in the discard
i'm kinda uh I'm kind of loving it and
then somebody points out oh boy we've
made a mess of this channel you did but
I'm getting amusement out of it I don't
know if anyone else is I'll probably
come back to find everybody has gone
away uh
we demand tea oh dear
do you think we'll get hell-bent to
electric Boogaloo on Sunday oh god I
hope not
I really really hope not serious
question if you could meet one Doctor
Who actor that you haven't already who
would it be and why is it Peter Capaldi
because he's my favorite doctor
I'm from Bensonhurst Brooklyn how long
were you in New York and what years I
was in New York for four years from 2006
to 2010 uh could you see an episode of
of a doctor going back or forward in
time into a situation where a previous
doctor was in they could I'd rather they
didn't again that's a little bit close
to sort of the masturbatory style of
narrative that I rather they didn't I've
made a lot of allusions to masturbation
this thing how much you want about this
the archived version of this gets T
monetized all right and I'm back in the
regular chat so if you asked any
questions while I was doing all that ask
him again cuz I missed him um I could
see the master getting mad about Time
Lords originating from humans I could -
I still don't think they should do it
admit it you love it when we make a mess
of the chat disk well yes if the choice
is between silence and a mess I will
take the mess do you think Brendon might
be some big chicken all is setting up
for next season he said he was setting
things up for series 13 um no I'm
expecting that to get resolved I
wouldn't be shocked if the Joe Martin
doctor doesn't get properly resolved
into Linux series I'm picking on the
actor who played Eugene's kid slash God
in the Holy Terror honestly listen to a
13-time
and is still weird stop bleeping me also
stop leaving me in your doctor who
reviews
I haven't relisted the holy tear in a
while so I don't I'm having a hard time
like conjuring an accurate memory of
that child's voice that character's
voice I don't know if they actually had
a child actor doing that or not um but I
remember working for me I think the roof
doctor is the doctor copying the master
and body-snatching
beavers anally style also I got Harley's
blazer from the end of birds of prey
nice that um that thing's got it's not
plummeting off of its first weekend it
opened a lot softer than I think it
should have but it it's it's got
slightly better legs than you'd usually
get for something that opened the way it
did so that's that's a little reassuring
I'd like more adaptations of Doctor Who
novels on TV like the new ace and
thirteen book like we should bring back
ace like seriously they should just do
that whether they adapt that book or not
they should just do that I uh it'd be so
cool like I've read the book but it
would be so cool if ace just ran into
thirteen and realized who she was
immediately just started calling your
professor to the doctor's annoyance oh
that would make me so happy she's gotta
use the baseball bat pal the baseball
bat and the explosives ace was really
good stuff brendan is all of the past
characters literally every single
character who's ever been on the show
prior to this I like hell-bent and I
feel no shame I would never tell you
that you should feel shame I I don't get
mad at people for liking something that
I don't like generally and especially in
the case of like something like
Doctor Who episode I am envious that I
didn't enjoy it I am envious of the fact
that you did me however I hate it I just
hope the timeless child doesn't turn out
to be Harry Potter um
ha ah
all those sides in the background from
TMNT um not specifically they're just
sighs they're not they're not um
recreations of anything in particular I
think ace is canonically a lesbian I was
pretty sure they did that um either a
lesbian or bisexual I forget which it is
but which I'm down for 100% and I do
have to wrap up pretty soon um answer to
your Holy Terror question it was Sam
Kelly's voice pitch upward to sound
childish and creepy that makes sense
that's what they tend to do more often
than not with those sorts of things I
met ace in my home town con and Halifax
cool all I would like to meet her that'd
be cool so like at this point for Doctor
Who related folks I've met John
Barrowman I've met Frasier Heinz I've
met Pro Mackey I've met Peter Davison
and I've met Christopher Eccleston
Doctor Who drinking game take a shot
when you see a British actor who was in
Game of Thrones take two shots when you
see an actor was in Harry Potter you
will be dead
there's one size fit all Gabe you
hmm aces probably buy as she had a
relationship with another companion hex
who was really likable he's a male nurse
role model as Florence Nightingale oh
cool
why am I so attracted to you because you
have working eyes I think on that no
work about her Oh before I get myself in
trouble
the timeless child is Sam Beckett oh god
sake yeah no no we're gonna wrap up um
I've had John Barrowman it's like I keep
getting rope back in you pulled me back
in my John Barrowman Matt Smith Peter
Capaldi so far I hope I get to meet many
more classic doctors and companions
mainly hope Davison didn't see your
doctor ranking pretty sure he didn't but
anyway thanks everybody for tuning in
fingers crossed for a good finale on
Sunday and I'll be back to do this again
in in two weeks so should be back on to
the seven o'clock time again sorry I had
to shift it to a little bit later life
happened nothing bad just stuff that
needed attention so um thanks so much
for tuning in thanks for being here
thanks for your support
your questions your everything just
being here so just remember that you are
beautiful you are valid you are loved
you are the counsel I'm just running
meetings have a good night everybody